si la france sort peu à peu de la crise
sanitaire pas de retour à la normale
pour autant mercredi le projet de loi
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale le
texte prévoit certaines restrictions
jusqu'au 30 octobre le font avec les
mots spital heures après trois mois de
crise sanitaire et l'instauration d'un
régime d'exception
la france va-t-elle enfin voir le bout
du tunnel
mercredi le texte organisons la sortie
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire à partir
du 10 juillet a été adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture
objectif lever les restrictions pesant
sur certaines libertés publiques pour
freiner l'épidémie
pour autant et pendant une période de
transition allant jusqu'à l'automne
le gouvernement se réserve le droit de
conserver certaines de ces mesures
telles que la restriction sur la
circulation des personnes
l'accueil du public ou encore
l'organisation de manifestations
l'opposition de droite comme de gauche
s'insurge contre un texte qualifié de
liberticide
on a un texte de loi qui nous dit que
c'est la fin de l'état d'urgence très
bien mais qui en fait par différentes
mesures la prolonge cette période avec
des interdictions ou des réglementations
d'aller et de venir du droit de
manifester fin des éléments quand même
important tout ça nous paraît vraiment à
contre-courant nous paraît dangereux
liberticide et ça ne nous va pas
évidemment on est quelques-uns à avoir
voté contre
essentiellement les deux les deux
premiers articles deuxième qui vise à
conserver les données
numérique alors qu'elle était censée
rester de manière provisoire tout de
même et puis le premier article là qui
empêche les réunions et les
manifestations ça c'est juste pas
possible en état de droit c'est
contraire à la constitution c'est
contraire à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme
de son côté le gouvernement se défend il
insiste sur le fait qu'une sortie
précipitée de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pourrait compromettre le retour à la
normale le texte adopté permettrait donc
d'après l'exécutif de réagir plus
efficacement face à une éventuelle
seconde vague du virus
il faut bien voir qu'il y avait
plusieurs intérêts en jeu et que d'un
côté vous avez les intérêts de santé
publique évident et dans tout le monde a
bien conscience et de l'autre côté il ya
les libertés individuelles et publiques
et il faut réussir à concilier ces deux
enjeux et c'est ce que nous avons fait
depuis l'origine aujourd'hui l'épidémie
n'est pas encore derrière nous nous
avons encore un virus qui circule sur le
territoire donc il ne faut pas oublier
les considérations sanitaires qui reste
essentiel et dont il faut protéger les
français donc la conciliation est
toujours à portée nous avons un regard
très vigilants à cet égard deux
exceptions sont prévues à cette sortie
de l'état d'urgence en guyane et à
mayotte où le virus continue de circuler
activement ce texte de loi doit
maintenant être examiné ce lundi par le
sénat